per ubriaco tosto e quello improvviso
silenzio complice spingo speciale della
serata e in diretta live grazie che sto
ca nato forse la cosa più orribile che
possa capitare a un essere umano da
adesso lo possiamo fare tutti basta ciao
ragazzi bentornati una nuova puntata di
vita buttata ora la scorsa settimana
avevo chiesto di suggerirmi un tema e
alla fine tra quelli che più sembravano
succulenti ce n'era una in particolare
il tema della puntata di oggi è ubriaca
toure
per un tema così importante e così
desiderato ho pensato di chiamare
all'interno degli studios the casa mia
un ospite è atteso da mesi forse da anni
prima ancora che vita buttate esistesse
qualcuno line dominato su facebook
stiamo parlando di niente poco di meno
ti claudio di biagio non lo devi
rimanere lì all'angolo mentre mentre io
sto con una persona immaginaria ciao
ciao claudio parliamo l'imbragatura più
avanti ti chiederò anche se ti sembra
complicato fingendo di non sapere che è
successo ok forse però ci sono delle
brega tour e che tu non ce n'è una in
avanti viene di partire subito ad
ascoltare i messaggi
se poi censurare i nomi te ne sono grato
e mascherare la voce rischio la morte
assolutamente no io dico nome e cognome
subito fatto proprio senso ricamificio è
il nostro tempo ma metti ma se un
professionista del web ma anche quello
che in una gita con i miei amici di
scuola firenze a un certo punto in un
vicino ma non ho dato il mio amico e gli
dico eric stasera agnese dopo pochi
secondi di semplici non ha mica il 10 a
guardare la under brutta ellen thermos
con la barba vera perché ancora che
prima aveva limato per tre ore in bagno
non stava rivelando la caldaia
ok va bene mai allora avevo bevuto
davvero ma davvero troppo mi trovo
davanti la porta di casa
nato per aprire non trovo le chiavi sono
che non potevo suonerà quell'ora sono i
miei mi ammazzavano letteralmente
problema è che mi stavo dicendo addosso
in di la cosa più razionale che gli
venne in mente di fare quella di urinare
dentro il porto belli per vicino a mio
avviso sfortuna che in quel momento uscì
proprio di casa privi degli col mio pene
in mano e mi fisso a 10 secondi ombre
lemme
dopo iniziò a urlare dicendomi che avevo
problemi psichiatrici e si può biasimare
questo ma la cosa interessante sono i 10
secondi di silenzio io lei è pazzo si se
ragione ma e lawrence no di volumi ogni
tanto lui inventati ovviamente ci torno
a casa a dormire con una mia amica in
condizioni pietose e mi alzo durante la
notte per andare in bagno
da lì vuoto totale black out il nulla
finché il mattino dopo
non sento mia nonna raccontare mia madre
che ha trovato uno nella vasca da bagno
aspetto non ho capi cioè mi manca un
pezzo è un pezzo stadio anche lei mi
mancava un pezzo perché io per esempio
ho avuto un black out ne conta sui cieli
puliti avuto un black out di un paio
d'ore perché ha avuto se non sbaglio
tipo 5 invisibili e due angeli azzurri
non so quanto sia dei pratici c'è
invisibile angeles un esempio
l'apparizione di me che è presente
quello che si concede con due comite
considera che io ero vestito da
chirichetto e andiamo avanti
in quelle due ore mi sono state
raccontate delle cose un po strane nelle
settimane successive hanno approfittato
della mia bocca
alcune ragazze alcune persone che mi
hanno baciato immagino di sì
improvvisamente io mi risveglio nel
parco è esattamente dove abbiamo girato
3x ho fatto la cacca nel parco
ho tirato su il mio gustato mestre nella
mia veste e da lì non ho più trovato il
mio costume da chirichetto io non sono
tornato a casa con questo meglio non so
cosa abbia fatto con quel persone tutti
si è alzato la testa e con la torta
completamente non lo so però non ho più
trovato tra ragazzi cos'è che vi
rivelarvi ero veramente felice
il vento per ascendere si sa per far
commuovere tu sei entrato con la veste
candida dell'adolescenza del bambino che
è in te ma quella sera tutti quei baci
hanno strappato col innocenza né te e tu
hai perso note oneste
in spagna 5 anni fa con degli amici e
volevo confessare tutte le ragazze a
questo drink conosco stati pavan temi
amici l'idea passione registi non tutti
la pensano bravo decise di variarlo anzi
lega è la felice di tutto ciò ma mi ha
iniziato a tenere violetta verità
schiassi e io voglio difendermi byatt ai
100 euro
quando tu sei arrabbiato non abbai ma
quanto sei felice di qualcosa godín soli
faccia molestia questo è uno volesse non
si fa io vorrei raccontarti cosa mi è
capitato di porterete tir termiti menti
ascolta il vocal esperienza super
divertente alla se non è super di
perdente devo raccontarti la mia
esperienza io faccio la guida turistica
sul napoli quindi è stato puro che vanno
per la maggiore sono poche capri non
lavoro con gli italiani ma con gli
stranieri principalmente vabbè ero a
capri quest'estate con questo gruppo di
americani fighissimi della mia riforma
fantinelli rilassati per chi aveva
pagato tutto la facciamo dell'isola
arrivati al porto era totalmente ubriaco
ad ammettere che amico sulla banchina
questo cade a mare e porto sapevo se
ridere o se piange io lo sono tutti i
marinai del porto alla tirarlo sopra lo
è tranquillissimo saliamo sulla lista e
lo è continua continua e distribuito
distribuendo bicchieri e oplà sia tutto
l'aliscafo non sono il mio gruppo a
tutta la gente del prof
g questi bicchieri continua a versare di
limoncello a tutti
in cui è presente men in black
se quando l'alieno entra dentro il corpo
del tizio si è la gara be like abile nei
carabi lei e led da rapido male se non
tanto per un'auto in corsa della madre
[Risate]
[Musica]
che mi stava affatto tutta la vita da
fare per la vita sull'aspetto
giustamente faccia così non me la vicina
nozioni e poi prima del solito extractor
dentro di me perche se venezia
ora ci auguriamo che ha dato anche la
polizia
in fondo prima di queste davanti sono
fermata quella voce integri da
quell'esperienza e non mise mai solo
borse riaversi notturno vi ho visto
[Risate]
perché meno sinclair di verziano dentro
al coni e lavora tanto e chiaro la
sorella del cicoria brava mamma viene
vietata